well here's an interesting new poll it's
from Siena College and it shows that
Alexander at Kazuya Cortes has wasted no
time in becoming deeply unpopular among
voters in her home state of New York a
total of 33 percent of those polled said
they liked
Acacio Cortez a whopping 44% did not how
did someone who's been in Congress only
a few months turn off so many people and
so quickly
well the congresswoman has already
answer for that as she does for most
things as she explained on Twitter
Republicans working in concert with that
dastardly Fox News quote authorize and
demonize anyone who isn't quote a white
male in other words it's bigotry pure
and simple those may look like bad poll
numbers what they really are is racism
now it's possible you will scoff at this
explanation it is whiny and predictable
and totally self-serving it's also
unsupported by evidence
so skepticism is a fair response well
let's go a little deeper for a second
what we have here is not simply a
cynical excuse for personal failings
when we've heard a thousand times from
politicians racism what Acacio Cortez
has given us instead is a litmus test
for our souls it's simple when you agree
with Alexandria Acacio Cortez you are a
good person when you disagree with her
you are not you're a racist a bigot a
hater a lonesome human being got that
okay prepare for the exam we're not
proctoring this test we're on TV right
now and you're at home or in a bar we're
gonna have to use the honor system here
we're gonna play you a series of clips
now be honest about how you feel about
them everything hangs in the balance
first we're gonna consider a o'seas
views on children she doesn't have any
and there's a reason for that she cares
too much her heart is too big watch her
explain our planet is going a disaster
if we don't turn the ship around and so
it's basically like there's scientific
is that the lives of children are going
to be very difficult and it does lead I
think young people to have a legitimate
question you know should is it okay to
still have children is it okay to still
have children that is a o'seas question
to you now if you answered are you
kidding of course it's okay to have
children and by the way back off you
authoritarian creep how many kids I have
is none of your business
if you answer it that way you failed the
test you're probably a white supremacist
if on the other hand you paused for a
moment thought deeply about climate
change and realize that actually some
unmarried 29 year old member of Congress
probably should be in charge of your
childbearing decisions than
congratulations you passed you are
virtuous not a racist at all okay on to
number two this one's about food my
Twitter mentions I'm getting a lot of
references about cow farts I think
that's a reference to your green new
deal yeah you explain that for us gotta
address factory farming maybe we
shouldn't be eating a hamburger for
breakfast lunch and dinner so the
question is how many hamburgers should
you be allowed to eat in the course of a
day now there are two possible answers
here the first is huh what kind of
question is that isn't this America and
hey stop eating off my plate that
unfortunately is the racist answer it's
the one that Bull Connor would have
given if he were still alive enough to
eat Big Macs the correct answer is I
will eat exactly as many hamburgers as
congresswoman Acacio Cortez allows me to
eat and I will be grateful for them if
that was your response congratulations
to you you are a good person now to
number three this one's about
immigration those women and children
trying to come here with nothing but the
shirts on their back to create an
opportunity and to provide for this
nation are acting more in an American
tradition than this president is right
now so the question is who is more
American actual Americans or foreigners
who spit on our customs and mock our
laws by sneaking into our country
illegally and calling us racist if we
try to make them leave this is a tough
one keep thinking okay times up the
answer is illegal aliens are the real
Americans duh if you doubted that for a
second please hate yourself you deserve
it and now for the final question on our
test this one is the Daily Double
see how you do criticisms of you is that
your math is fuzzy the Washington Post
recently awarded you four Pinocchios
I think that there's a lot of people
more concerned about being precisely
factually and semantically correct than
about being morally right factually
correct now this question gets right to
the heart of it all are you one of those
troglodyte sister still cares about
facts about numbers and evidence and
physical reality it's 2019 man
physics is just a preference if you
persist in being factually correct and
continue to read books speak in complete
sentences please know that you are
committing racism you sir are a bigot
and congresswoman Acacio Cortes condemns
you she by contrast is morally right and
utterly certain of it on this test that
is all that matters